Let's say that I'm able to go
out and survey every single
member of a population, which
we know is not normally
practical, but I'm
able to do it.
And I ask each of them, what do
you think of the president?
And I ask them, and there's
only two options, they can
either have an unfavorable
rating or they could have a
favorable rating.
And let's say after I survey
every single member of this
population, 40% have an
unfavorable rating and 60%
have a favorable rating.
So if I were to draw the
probability distribution, and
it's going to be a discrete one
because there's only two
values that any person
can take on.
They could either have an
unfavorable view or they could
have a favorable view.
And 40% have an unfavorable
view, and let me color code
this a little bit.
So this is the 40% right over
here, so 0.4 or maybe I'll
just write 40% right
over there.
And then 60% have a
favorable view.
Let me color code this.
60% have a favorable view.
And notice these two numbers
add up to 100% because
everyone had to pick between
these two options.
Now if I were to go and ask you
to pick a random member of
that population and say what is
the expected favorability
rating of that member,
what would it be?
Or another way to think about it
is what is the mean of this
distribution?
And for a discrete distribution
like this, your
mean or you're expected value
is just going to be the
probability weighted sum of the
different values that your
distribution can take on.
Now the way I've written it
right here, you can't take a
probability weighted sum of u
and f-- you can't say 40%
times u plus 60% times
f, you won't get
any type of a number.
So what we're going to do
is define u and f to be
some type of value.
So let's say that u
is 0 and f is 1.
And now the notion of taking a
probability weighted sum makes
some sense.
So that mean, or you could say
the mean, I'll say the mean of
this distribution it's going
to be 0.4-- that's this
probability right here times 0
plus 0.6 times 1, which is
going to be equal to-- this
is just going to be
0.6 times 1 is 0.6.
So clearly, no individual can
take on the value of 0.6.
No one can tell you I 60%
am favorable and 40% am
unfavorable.
Everyone has to pick either
favorable or unfavorable.
So you will never actually find
someone who has a 0.6
favorability value.
It'll either be a 1 or a 0.
So this is an interesting case
where the mean or the expected
value is not a value that
the distribution can
actually take on.
It's a value some place
over here that
obviously cannot happen.
But this is the mean, this
is the expected value.
And the reason why that makes
sense is if you surveyed 100
people, you'd multiply 100 times
this number, you would
expect 60 people to say yes,
or if you'd summed them all
up, 60 would say yes, and
then 40 would say 0.
You sum them all up, you would
get 60% saying yes, and that's
exactly what our population
distribution told us.
Now what is the variance?
What is the variance of this
population right over here?
So the variance-- let me write
it over here, let me pick a
new color-- the variance is
just-- you could view it as
the probability weighted sum of
the squared distances from
the mean, or the expected value
of the squared distances
from the mean.
So what's that going to be?
Well there's two different
values that
anything can take on.
You can either have a 0 or you
could either have a 1.
The probability that you get a
0 is 0.4-- so there's a 0.4
probability that you get a 0.
And if you get a 0 what's the
distance from 0 to the mean?
The distance from 0 to the mean
is 0 minus 0.6, or I can
even say 0.6 minus 0-- same
thing because we're going to
square it-- 0 minus 0.6
squared-- remember, the
variance is the weighted sum
of the squared distances.
So this is the difference
between 0 and the mean.
And then plus, there's a 0.6
chance that you get a 1.
And the difference between
1 and 0.6, 1 and our
mean, 0.6, is that.
And then we are also going
to square this over here.
Now what is this value
going to be?
This is going to be 0.4 times
0.6 squared-- this is 0.4
times point-- because 0 minus
0.6 is negative 0.6.
If you square it you
get positive 0.36.
So this value right here-- I'm
going to color code it.
This value right here
is times 0.36.
And then this value right
here-- let me do this in
another-- so then we're going to
have plus 0.6 times 1 minus
0.6 squared.
Now 1 minus 0.6 is 0.4.
0.4 squared is 0.16.
So let me do this.
So this value right here
is going to be 0.16.
So let me get my calculator
out to actually calculate
these values.
So this is going to be 0.4 times
0.36, plus 0.6 times
0.16, which is equal to 0.24.
So our standard deviation of
this distribution is 0.24.
Or if you want to think about
the variance of this
distribution is 0.24 and the
standard deviation of this
distribution, which is just the
square root of this, the
standard deviation of this
distribution is going to be
the square root of 0.24, and
let's calculate what that is.
That is going to be-- let's take
the square root of 0.24,
which is equal to 0.48-- well
I'll just round it up-- 0.49.
So this is equal to 0.49.
So if you were look at this
distribution, the mean of this
distribution is 0.6.
So 0.6 is the mean.
And the standard deviation
is 0.5.
So the standard deviation is--
so it's actually out here--
because if you go add one
standard deviation you're
almost getting to 1.1, so this
is one standard deviation
above, and then one standard
deviation below gets you right
about here.
And that kind of makes sense.
It's hard to kind of have a good
intuition for a discrete
distribution because you really
can't take on those
values, but it makes sense
that the distribution is
skewed to the right over here.
Anyway, I did this example
with particular numbers
because I wanted to
show you why this
distribution is useful.
In the next video I'll do
these with just general
numbers where this is going
to be p, where this is the
probability of success and this
is 1 minus p, which is
the probability of failure.
And then we'll come up with
general formulas for the mean
and variance and standard
deviation of this
distribution, which is actually
called the Bernoulli
Distribution.
It's the simplest case of the
binomial distribution.